hi everyone i'm dvgen
in this video i'm going to talk about
one of the simplest behaviors kinesis
kinesis is a way that very simple
organisms like this hypothetical slime
here can wander into good areas and stay
there without actually understanding
what they're doing
all right here's my world in unity and
here's our little slime the issue the
slime has is his body is made of slime
it is very vulnerable to desiccating in
hot dry conditions
unfortunately it is a very simple
creature
it has extremely simple sensory organs
it does not have complex neural
architecture
and that means it actually cannot detect
the direction of hot danger or cool
safety
the slime can know of its own body is
hot or dry or cool or moist
but it does not have the ability to know
what direction to go
if it wants to become cool it just
cannot sense that what it can do though
is use kinesis
kinesis is a non-directional change in
activity in response to a stimulus
what i mean by this is
it can detect if its own body is hot and
then maybe move more
but it doesn't actually see heat or
detect heat and go away from it kinesis
is a non-directional change it's never a
way or towards the stimulus
what can happen with simple creatures
like this slime
is they can randomly sort of wander into
an area that's not good for them and
that will make them move faster or it'll
make them turn more
that will cause them to hopefully get
out of that area
and then if they randomly wander into an
area that's nice they'll maybe move a
little slower and turn a little less
and that will cause them to stay in that
area a little bit longer
ultimately kinesis means a simple
creature like our slime
can incidentally wander into the right
place
and stay there
and have no idea how it did that
all right
let's try this
i'm gonna put 250 slimes into this
container
the left side is too hot but the right
side is the perfect cool temperature the
slimes have no idea what's going on
they can't tell what direction is hot
what direction is cool
you'll see them bump into each other and
bump into the walls
their little eye spots are pretty much
just there so i know what direction
they're facing they really can't do a
whole lot they can however detect if
their own body is cool or warm and if
they stumble into the red area they're
going to feel warmer and if they stumble
into the blue area they're going to feel
cooler
what the slimes can do
is use kinesis
to adjust their random wandering
behavior if they become too warm they
will move a little faster and they will
turn a little more
if they become cool they will move a
little slower and turn a little less
so the slimes don't really know what
they're doing
they don't really know where they're
going
but because they can use kinesis they
will mostly end up in the cool blue zone
in the real world kinesis is a strategy
that's used by a lot of simple organisms
like planarians or roly-poly isopods
it's used by a lot of simple creatures
to get them into a good place probably a
lot of unicellular creatures probably a
lot of microscopic creatures probably a
lot of things that aren't actually
animals can use kinesis
kinesis is really useful for simple
creatures
because that's all they've got that's
the best they can do
but it can still be used by more complex
creatures too
let's talk about implementation
i'm using the unity game engine you can
use any other game engine you want
unreal
whatever you can program this and and
just other things doesn't matter i'm
gonna hit the core concepts
here's my saline prefab in unity it has
all the standard unity things but the
first thing that's relevant is this
creatures stats section this is where i
intend to put all the creature stats for
right now i only have this satisfaction
level
when the slimes wander into the red area
that's detected and that decreases the
satisfaction level a little bit if they
wander into the blue area that increases
the satisfaction level for a little bit
right now i have just these two areas
affecting overall satisfaction but you
could have things like a temperature
variable if you want temperature-based
kinesis you could have a light variable
if you wanted a light based kinesis you
could have a hunger variable if you
wanted a hunger-based kinesis
right now i'm just going to put
everything in this one core trade
up next i have this wandering section
and this is where i keep all the
settings for the random wandering
behavior right now my creatures can just
move fast or slow and they can turn in
small angles or they can turn in big
angles i'm still making a lot of
adjustments here really it's up to you
to implement this how you want
the point i'd like to make is notice i
have two sets of wandering settings i
have one for when the creatures are
discontent and one for when the
creatures are content
to implement kinesis what needs to
happen is that satisfaction level needs
to determine which wandering setting to
use
and in fact i blend between them
i'm using the entity component system in
unity dots
here is basically what my code looks
like
i find every entity that has a wandering
component and a creature stats component
and then i use that satisfaction level
to interpolate between two wonder
settings
if you wanted to use unity's classic
game object model behavior workflow
then your code might look something like
this
if you wanted to use some other game
engine some other programming language
the core aspect of the kinesis would be
blend between
multiple wondering settings based on
some sort of input
again i'm using an overall satisfaction
level but this could be specific to
temperature humidity food levels air
quality anything you can think of i'll
also leave it to you to implement your
specific code because it could be
anything
you could have climbing jumping flying
digging whatever stuff as long as the
stimulus change
doesn't produce any behavior that goes
toward a stimulus or away from a
stimulus
then you're talking about kinesis
well that's it for this video i'll leave
by letting you watch the slimes play for
a little bit if you have any questions
or comments or thoughts feel free to
reach out i'm always happy to chat about
behavior until then happy simulating and
happy sliming
you